so interestingly here's an implication
this is bit bit of a digression here if
hegel's correct in
this this means that the whole question
of whether Consciousness is reducible to
the brain or whether you know we have
something like a cartisian dualism where
there's spirit and then you know the
corporeal
organ that's kind of a non-starter
actually within the hallan framework
because of course you have an organ but
that organ itself can be understood in
two ways in an objective way which
treats it essentially as a dead thing
even if it treats it as a supposedly
living system and then the other way
which is to say it is it is infused with
or it is integrated with spirit and not
just in like you know High per forming
individuals
everybody so he goes on now I mean
consider that too another
digression Hegel has no problem with a
sort of evolutionary perspective on the
development of of human being and all
that at a certain point we get a
creature whose brain function is able to
be a sufficient vehicle for Spirit for
Guist for something that we could never
guess would have come on the scene and
we we get to know sort of according to
Hegel after the fact after it's gone
through its process of development
keep the actuality an existence of a
person of an
individual is that skull that you can
feel that you can look for bumps under
the hair maybe shave the head so you can
see the bumps a little bit better a
little bit of a digression here I
remember when I went in the Army there's
there's a time that that happens where
you know you're you're all recruits and
people come in with all sorts of hair
and then everybody goes to the barber
and it all gets shaved off and suddenly
people look you know very strange not
just because they don't have hair but
you look at some people and you're like
wow that guy's got a funny head and
other people you look at and you're like
that guy doesn't look too bad bald some
people you look at and they've got big
scars and all sorts of things you're
like wow what happened to you well
that's that's because that's the
externality that is being existence for
another I can look at your head once
it's shaved and say that's a big knot
you got there on your head how' you get
that because you exist for another that
way that's how we exist in the world a
world full of others and we're reducing
as as doing the
phenology uh path we're reducing a
person down to their skull down to what
is exhibit we might say so he says um
this is how the relationship and the two
sides of this relation are understood by
the Consciousness observing them this is
how
observation observing Consciousness goes
in the wrong direction in the
pseudoscience of
phenology now notice that for a lot of
philosophers the purer and more abstract
it is the better it is not for Hegel
Hegel thinks if we want to here Hegel
let me let me preface this this sort of
an aside here Hegel is placing himself
within a long loose tradition of
philosophers who think that you don't do
philosophy well by getting away from
reality that you have to take in you
don't just you know come up with an
bunch of ideas and then press them on to
reality and say so much the worse for
reality you got to take your cues from
reality who would that include Aristotle
for one right uh in the Middle Ages
Thomas aquinus would be another great
example in the early modern period who
might you look to I would say blae
Pascal is is a great example of that
sort of thing and finally you know in
the the you know 19th century we have we
have Hegel on the scene saying you got
to take account of everything and that's
actually where the hegelian system shows
its weaknesses it's not in um you know
what it does well it's where it has has
sometimes failed to go as far as it
could in grasping concrete individuality
that's K guard's complaint in grasping
what's going on in material economic
processes that's Mark's complaint you
know in um making sense out of what's
really happening in terms of the the
individual and um Enlightenment and and
religion that's Maurice blondell's point
we can go on and on and on but all of
those are working off of a Hegel who
went about as far as that you can go
with this in part because he rejected
pure empty abstraction he said that's
just a starting point that's not where
philosophy ought to
remain
pleasure is something thing that we
could see as
happiness precisely because we do enjoy
it right and if we don't enjoy it
directly at least somebody else talks to
us about it and says oh my gosh you have
to experience this this is so amazing so
wonderful I'm willing to pay ,000 for
this experience and we're like w that
person thinks it's pretty good maybe
there's really something to that and you
know if you think about it there's a bit
of an aside so so many magazines so many
websites are based solely around this
premise of somebody else experiencing
something and then giving us some
guidelines about that I mean even some
of the ones about the life of the Mind
are along those lines oh you haven't
read Oscar wild um well you don't know
what you've cut yourself off from oh you
haven't read PRS you know uh Monumental
Opus which I'll admit I haven't read I I
I started reading it and got really you
know tired of fairly quickly and decided
I didn't need to spend any more time on
it
um all these Realms and ranges of
pleasure offer us the possibility of
enjoyment what
is